i've been on the team for two years now
it's just a winning culture winning
environment my goal on the court just
continue to try to repeat what we did
last year winning a championship it
wasn't easy but it's something we feel
we could do again
susie i guess one of the biggest things
about performance solutions is that
we're trying to have a collaborative and
integrative partnership that truly
impacts performance you obviously had a
very successful season last year what
area of research are you looking forward
to most in the coming years we don't
know
much about this population group there's
no real research out there you know what
is the energy expenditure of this group
we just don't know right so we've got a
fun journey ahead as we get to know more
about them um as individuals so i think
we'll be world leading by doing that we
have championship aspirations every
possession
every game every rebound everything
matters here
the difference between the season and
the playoffs is for the starting five
their minutes on court
increases hugely we start
changing their minutes on course we
start changing their nutrition
i'll introduce extra fueling into them
at half time that i don't need to do
during the season so definitely there's
a
different plan that needs to be followed
as you practice that leading into the
time of the playoffs
the further you go in the playoffs the
harder it is the better shape you have
to be so to want to take care of my mind
and also to take care of my body to
withstand a long season
susie's
role is very vital and important to us
and she does a great job in getting the
game making sure that we're getting the
right you know all the all the right
nutrition and things like that from day
to day and she's just a great person to
have um it's always good to have someone
genuine on the side
when you win everyone's looking at what
you're doing and so every single player
coach sports science staff how do i be
10 better
because i need to be if we're going to
win it twice in a row and that's where
the partnership with sis will support
that
it's important not to be complacent
because we won't